Here, we're going to
talk about metacognition.
Metacognition is thinking about
thinking, or knowing what you know.
It's really any thought process,
where the target of the thought process,
is actually inside you're own brain.
So it might be thinking about
what you're thinking about,
or knowing what knowledge that you have.
Now, a key type of metacognition,
in learning, is called self-regulated
learning.-Self regulated learning is the
process by which a person plans out how
they're going to learn something,
monitors how learning is going,
evaluates it, and
then adjusts it accordingly.
Self-regulated learning is really
the goal that we want students to reach.
We want them to become self-regulated
learners because it's more about
active learning rather
than passive learning.
It's about driving your own learning
process as opposed to being a passive
consumer of whatever information
is presented to you.
Now a key part of self-regulated
learning is the mindset that one has
towards learning.
There are a lot of people out
there that think they have
a fixed amount of intelligence, that
they are as smart as they'll ever be,
and if they can't do something it's
just because they aren't smart enough.
That's not really an accurate
way of framing intelligence.
Intelligence is much more something that
we can work at, we can grow through.
Through effort and intensive study we
can actually get smarter, effectively.
Now I think everybody has that one book
that they recommend that everybody read
and mine is actually on this topic.
Carol Dweck is a Stanford psychologist
who spent decades working on motivation
and learning, especially at the lower,
middle and high school levels.
And what she found was that ability
does not necessarily predict success at
the next level.
But the mindset that one
has towards learning and
towards intelligence is really
the chief predictor at whether or
not someone will be
successful at the next level.
She found that those people who
recognized that failure is just
an opportunity to learn, as opposed to
a referendum on one's own intelligence,
are really the ones who
succeed at the next level.
So I highly recommend picking
up this book, especially for
both designing educational
technology and for self-improvement.
So in this lesson what we're going to
talk about is really how to use
technology to facilitate
metacognitive development.
We'll talk about how technology can give
a kind of open-ended and self-driven
opportunities to students that would
be difficult in a regular classroom.
Typically classrooms are driven
by a lesson and a lecture and
it can be difficult to give students
the opportunity to drive what they're
learning In time.
But through technology,
we can build more open-ended
environments in which the learner
is put into the driver's seat.
And they get to control what they
learn and when, and how, and
learn at that process of monitoring it
and planning it, and evaluating it.
So we'll talk about how technology
can really facilitate meta-cognative
development